[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Welcome to the
Data Science
Hangout. Hope
everyone's having a great week.
I'm Rachael. I lead our
Pro Community at Posit.
And if this is your first
time joining us here,
special welcome to you.
This is our open space
to chat about data science leadership,
questions you're facing,
and getting to hear about
what's going on in the world of
data across many
different industries.
And so we're here every--
I say every single Thursday.
There have been some Thursdays
where we haven't been here for
holidays or something.
But same time, same place.
So if you're watching this
on YouTube into the future,
if you want to join us live,
you can use the link in the
details to add it to your calendar
and join the party
with us. But together,
we're all dedicated to making
this a welcoming environment for everyone.
And we love hearing from you
all no matter your level of
experience or area of work.
So it's totally OK to just
listen in, if you want.
But if you want to jump
in and ask questions or provide your
own perspective
on certain topics,
there's a few ways
that you can do that.
So you can raise your
hand here on Zoom.
And if you're not sure how
to do that, it's in the
controls down below.
But you can also put
questions into the Zoom chat.
And feel free to put a little
star next to it if you want to
me to read it out loud,
instead if you're in a
coffee shop or something.
And then lastly, we
have a Slide-A-Link,
where you can ask
questions anonymously, too.
And our team should share that in
the chat here in just a second.
If not, let me know
and I can share it.
But I'm so excited to have
Katherine joining me as our co-host today.
Katherine Gerton is manager of
data analytics and recording at Centene.
And Katherine,
I'd love to kick things
off with having you introduce
yourself and share a little
bit about your role and also
something you like to
do outside of work.
- Yeah.
Hi, I'm Katherine Gerton.
I, as Rachel said,
am the manager of data
analytics and reporting at Centene.
In that role,
I actually support our
Health Insurance Affordable Care Act
Marketplace products.
Supporting the Risk
Adjustment Mandate,
that's part of that work.
I put it in my bio. But
when I am not working,
I play volleyball. And
I do a lot of sewing.
And so I've been working on--
that's what I got better at
during the pandemic, was I decided
to get actually good at sewing
more than a rectangle and started
making my own clothes.
So that is what I do.
I see we've got somebody else
in the chat who's also working
in risk adjustment.
So that's nice.
I didn't want to get too into
the weeds on what that actually is.
But I'm more than happy to fill
that in for anyone who doesn't know.
- I also have to ask you,
what's one of your
favorite things that you've sewed?
- I was really
proud, actually, of
a pair of jeans
that I made that I
embroidered with outlines
of different fruit.
- That's amazing.
- They don't currently fit.
So they're not
getting a lot of use.
But they were really
great when I made them. So
we'll see if they get a little
bit more wear here in the future.
- I would not know
how to even start
making jeans. That's amazing.
Well, Katherine,
I know something that we had
talked a little bit about and
was shared in advance
of the hangout
was about the power
of embedded teams
or bridging the gap between a
lot of cool data science the
team's doing, and
then meaningful business insights.
And I thought it might be
helpful to just understand a
little bit about the
data analytics team structure at
Centene and what
that looks like.
- Yeah. So we have--
it's kind of a hybrid between
your traditional centralized team
and your embedded teams
within your business areas.
So we have Centene
Technologies corporate IT--
kind of data science,
data analytics,
where they support a lot of
the tech stack, but also facilitate
conversations with business teams
that may not have their
own analyst. They help
gather requirements,
build some of those models.
And then we also have teams,
like the one that I'm a
part of within the actuarial
department, where we
are a data science team.
We are involved in
gathering the requirements,
building the tools
to support that
business process,
and then interfacing with
the centralized teams that do
control and maintain the
tech stack for us. So that's
really what we look like.
And I would say I'm super
grateful to be a part of that
because not having to know
how computers work or how software
is built, and installed,
and maintained,
and all of that is great for me.
I've tried to learn it.
It's not something I really
understand easily. And it frees
me up to not have to really
dig into that. I can spend
my mental energy focusing on, OK,
these are the data science
problems. Also, my cat is here.
These are the data
science problems
that are facing my business unit
and can really dig into those problems.
- OK. We're going to have
to introduce your cat, too.
- OK. That's Timber.
We got her from the street.
- Aw, so cute.
- Yes. And my dog is
around here somewhere.
Yeah, he's over there snoozing.
- He might make an
appearance, too?
Awesome. Well,
I know you said you weren't
thinking about giving an
overview about risk adjustment.
- Risk adjustment?
- But while we're here and
Libby asked it, so why don't
we-- why don't we?
- Yeah. So when the
Affordable Care Act
was put into place in about
2015, one of the things
that was mandated there
is insurance companies can no
longer deny people coverage
for pre-existing conditions.
So it doesn't matter
what conditions you have.
You have to get insurance.
You can't discriminate based on rates
for those conditions that someone has.
So one of the things that is
in place in order to ensure that
happens is what's
called risk adjustment.
And so throughout the year,
all health insurance companies
submit their claims data and
their diagnosis data for
their entire populations to these
government-maintained servers. And then you
get credit for the risk.
So members have certain
conditions that counts them as
risky or not risky.
There's a bunch of interaction factors
and a whole lot of math
involved in calculating
how much risk a member has.
And so then at the end of
the year is when the risk
adjustment takes place.
So insurers who insure a
riskier population actually get
transfer dollars from the
insurers who insure a less
risky population. So it's
entirely budget-neutral. There's no
government money involved
in changing hands.
They facilitate that transfer between
those insurers, but not anything else.
So if one insurer insures
a bunch of elderly people
with multiple comorbidities and one
insurer insures a bunch
of healthy college students,
the one who insures a
bunch of healthy college students is
going to owe money to that other
insurer at the end of the year,
just to say
we're covering more
risk than you are.
And then there's the process-- so
I have a sister team who's
involved in the risk
adjustment. And I
am in charge of the audit
of the risk adjustment.
So once you've submitted
all of this data,
the government takes a
representative sample of your
population and comes back
to you and says, prove it.
Prove that these members have the
conditions that you say that they have.
So we have to go and collect
medical records, talk to
doctors, code all
of those records,
and then recalculate the risk,
and prove that the population
distribution is as risky as we
said it was throughout the year.
- Interesting. Yes,
Libby said in the chat,
that sounds like a
huge data project.
What are some of the
projects that you work on in
analytics that come after that?
-
So there's a huge part
of this that's actually competitive
intelligence analytics, where,
because it is budget-neutral
and there's transfers between
different insurers, you know
how risky your own population
is. But you don't
really know a lot about
the other insurers'
populations.
So there's a lot of
data gathering, data aggregation around
that relative risk analytics.
And then we also have
a bunch of analytics involved
with predicting which
conditions are going
to be easy to validate,
which ones are going
to be more difficult,
what pieces of information
might we need to gather in the
aspect of conducting this audit
in order to validate these
conditions. So that's all
the post-hoc analytics.
And then we also have
a lot of perspective analytics around
identifying members that we
think may have conditions that
they haven't seen their doctor for yet
this year end closing those care gaps.
-
This is reminding me of when
Rebecca Hadi joined us as well
and her cat was front
and center during the Hangout.
- Yeah. She, of course, as
soon as I joined the call,
decided that she needed
immediate attention.
- That's how it goes.
- Yeah. So that's
like the overview
of risk adjustment.
And then some of the high level
work-- we're also involved--
since we are embedded in
the actuarial department,
there's a lot of
financial predictions and analytics
involved with forecasting,
and reserving,
and all of that kind of stuff
that comes off of the data that
you're gathering, but then
is involved with licensed
actuaries and that kind of
business side of the work.
- Thank you. I see, Libby,
you had a follow-up
question on the audits.
You want to jump in?
- Yeah,
I was just wondering if there's a
really busy time of year for you.
I know I've done audits.
And I have worked with audit
teams in different areas.
And there's always this really busy
month or week out of the quarter.
- Yeah. So we kicked
off the audit last week.
That was incredibly busy.
There's a lot of vendor data
hand-offs, where we have to gather
that information, pass
back to the government,
back to other vendors who help
us with certain aspects of the audit.
And then there's usually a
pretty busy season about two
months before the audit closes,
when you're trying to aggregate
all of the information that
you've gathered so
that you can submit it,
and then also do some of
those financial forecasts.
- Nice. So do you
have-- a follow-up--
do you have this period where
there is a little bit less
stuff to do and you're able
to start to work on problems that
would make it easier
for further audits?
- Yeah.
My team has been building a
lot of Shiny apps and a lot of
dashboards that we've been
deploying onto our Posit
Connect suite that track
how the audit is going,
where there might be
points of intervention,
if there's something
that's like, hey,
we're not doing it as well as
we were last year, flagging
that, sending emails,
a lot of that.
We've also
made some data portals,
where some of our internal
partners, where they might need
something in a specific format,
like an Excel file or a CSV
so that they can do some
additional work with it,
where they can upload data or
download our results in a way
that makes it really accessible
for them to continue doing
their work, but in more of
a self-service way, so it's not
an email to us,
and then we have to manually
create some sort of--
or even just manually
run an R script.
It's part of that
dashboarding. So we're actually
shifting into that
for this audit now,
like maintaining what
we've done in the past,
updating it with some
new tools, with some new
Shiny development,
as well as just--
there's always
lessons learned from
last year. It's like, oh,
we weren't tracking that,
but we really should have been.
And so we're tracking
it this year.
- I'd love to learn more
about that Shiny app, too. So
you mention people
can download the data
as well?
Is that people who typically
would want to be working with
Excel data? Or what
are they doing?
- Yeah.
So that's people who would want
to be working with Excel data or
we have-- so I sit at
Centene Corporate. But we also have
subsidiary health plans.
I have access to all of
our health plan data. But not
everyone who supports the audit
execution at the lower levels does.
So when they go in,
they can just see
the California data or just see
certain pre-filtered
sets of it that's really
tied to their login credentials,
all of that kind of stuff.
So then again, I don't
have to be like, OK,
who's asking for this? What
health plan do they support?
Filtering it on my end, we
were able to build those
things tied to their
internal login credentials.
And then they can just do it.
- That's great.
So a question we used
to ask in the beginning
of the Hangouts-- and I
don't know what happened,
where we stopped asking
this. But I'm curious,
what's something-- if you
look to the year ahead,
what's something that you're really
excited about for your team?
- We have been
working really hard on
turning some
OK
statistical models
into some machine
learning models,
where we can bring in some
different data types and get a
little bit more insight
out of that. So we have
a couple of different models
that are in the works around
estimating our final validation
rates for these audits or
estimating some of those
statewide competitive
intelligence variables.
And where it's something that we've
done in the past on an ad
hoc basis with
hand-grabbing different Excel files
and things like that,
so we've been working
really hard to
bake that into our
data science ecosystem,
where it runs on our
database queries.
And it gathers
things like that.
And we're currently in
the stage of figuring
out how to deploy those so
that people can access the results again.
The theme of a lot of the
work that we're doing is
not purely self-service,
but mostly self-service, where
somebody who wants this can
get it and knows how to get it.
- How do you market
those applications out across the
organization?
- For those applications,
we're not really
targeting whole organization reach.
We have a couple specific
partners during audit execution
that we really target with
those, where they've--
they'll ask us for an ad
hoc thing. And that's fine.
But if we get
those same requests
more than twice really, it's,
OK, let's put it together.
Here, it's going
to run every week.
It's going to come
straight to your inbox.
And everyone's like,
oh, this is great.
We haven't really had a
lot of pushback with those internal
teams on like, well no,
I really need you to
walk me through this
Excel file or things
like that, where--
and that's definitely something
I'm grateful for because it's
not something that
happens everywhere,
where the partners
that I work with are
fully on board to receive
automatic HTML markdowns in their inbox.
-
I see there is some
conversation in the chat going
on about Shiny frameworks. And I think,
Bill, you maybe had the
initial question here.
I don't know if you're
able to unmute, Bill.
Bill asked,
are you using any
specific Shiny frameworks like golem?
- No. We've actually had
a lot of success with
bs4Dash,
those interactive,
tabular kind of things.
So no really in-depth
Shiny frameworks-- a lot
of interactivity and a
lot of tabs and click-through.
But yeah, nothing super
high level Shiny,
more of just that
facilitating that interaction.
- Yeah.
And I see people are talking about
both rhino and golem as well. Alexis,
I wasn't sure if you wanted
to share any thoughts on this,
too. I see you
commenting in the chat.
- Yeah. Actually,
I've been trying-- rhino has
been a little bit more
oriented towards
software development. And
I think
a balance between golem and
for people that are just starting.
And if you want to
go more in depth,
I think I would go
with rhino. However,
I think golem has
been pretty good
as a starting point
for Shiny models.
- Yeah. I mean, I'll
add that I haven't-- because
the dashboards that I'm
building are really used by a
limited set of
internal partners,
I haven't really had to
worry about things like Shiny load
testing or all
of those kinds of
broader things that you worry
about when you build an app
that hundreds,
if not your whole company
of people is going to use.
If I have three people in
my app at the same time,
that's heavy use on
the app on that day,
just because
there's
not a lot of need for it.
So the most
complicated and
business-important app that
I've built is really-- it was
a way for me to have to not
email four people,
get four different versions
of an Excel sheet back,
and collapse it, and
then do analytics on it.
I made a portal
where they can go in,
everyone with their
login credentials,
edit basically the Excel file, but
in the Shiny app through an
rhandsontable format,
and save it in exactly
the format I want it.
And nobody can move anything.
And nobody can change data
types. And it's great.
But it's really specifically to
people who have those senior
coding level credentials and there's
like four of them that
support this audit. So I think, for my team,
business value is not measured in number
of users or reach of that app.
It's really the fact that this
saved us so much time and so
much money to do
it in this way that
that's the value of
this app for my team.
- OK. A lot of love
for rhandsontable
already. I was trying to find
just the quick link to it.
I'm not sure if that
was the right one.
But what does that
actually do, that package?
- So it lets you click
into a data frame,
and make edits, and save those
edits back out. So those edits
can then be redisplayed
to the user.
It's delightful. It's a
little bit hard to learn,
if you're used to maybe like
a GT or a DT data table.
But it's basically magical.
You can put this table in
your Shiny app. And people can
feel-- if you wanted to, you
could even make it green.
If you want people to really
feel like it's Excel, you can.
But you're basically
putting this in
your Shiny app. And
people are editing it.
You can say, this
is a date data type.
This is exactly the date
format that it's coming in.
This is going to be a number.
It's going to have
three decimal places.
And when they hit Save, that's
exactly what you get back.
And I have that link to
our S3 storage solution.
So every time somebody hits
Save, it's a separate record.
We can go back. We can
access historical records.
It's made my life so
much better. And I think
building tools that make
your own life better,
and then spreading them to
other people is still a really
valuable way to do work.
- Oh, I was just writing
that down to save that quote there.
I can feel the excitement in
the chat right now about people
just discovering
this package as well.
And
I need to look into it, too.
But it sounds like it would
be really helpful for the people
who have this use case of
they're working with business users
who still really want to
use Excel and
don't want to be
interacting with
a Shiny application, but maybe
need to download their own
Excel data as well.
- Yeah, it's great. And
then I'm not as comfortable with--
I think it's tidyxl.
But that's one of the
ones that enables you to--
when you write your format back
out to an Excel, you can bake
in formulas. Like if somebody
says, hey, I really need
this formula to come out
of it for some reason--
not static data,
let's make it somehow dynamic in
the Excel file that you're writing--
all of those things still work
together even through that Shiny backend.
- Awesome. Thank you.
Regis, I saw you had a
question in the chat.
I missed it with all
the comments here.
But if you want to jump in?
- Yeah.
Let me turn my camera
on really quick.
So I was just wondering-- Libby was
saying, yeah, so hopefully that's the case.
So I've made a couple
Shiny apps that require
tables that have editing. And the out
of the box tables that you make--
and maybe Joe Chang is going
to change this for future
iterations of Shiny.
But if you're on page 10
of a table that has 1,000
rows, and then you need to
change what's in the table, by default,
Shiny will reset that table back
to the first page of the table.
But
[? Huawei ?] has some
extensions for the DT package where
if you need to change
something in page 10, you can--
I think there's a Replace
Data function in the DT package.
And I'm just wondering if
rhandsondata has something like
that so that if
you're on page 10
and you're doing something
super fancy in rhandsontable
that it won't send
you back to page 1,
which will drive
everyone using it crazy.
- Yeah.
It's part of the
rhandsontable offering.
But when you click into a cell,
you can store that row and cell value.
So that's one of the things
that I do with the reactives
and the callbacks
is I store this.
And then you can index anything
that you're doing based on that
or send it back to pull up
this page, pull up this row.
Or any changes that you're
making can be tagged with that
cell that you've clicked in.
- But I mean, when you
change it on the backend,
the Shiny side, the R side, and
then you push it back to the interface,
does it,
make sure that it doesn't
set the table that it's displaying
back to the first page if
you edit something on the 10th page?
- I think there's probably
a way that you can do that
between your observers
versus eventReactives
because observers, I think,
execute all the time.
So if you put your table
render in an observe,
it's going to automatically
go. But if you wait,
you can save it and have
it wait to rerender until after
you click some other button. So you can
store all of that data, and then not
render your table
until you're ready.
And I think you can
also set it to render--
if you save that page, you
can have it rerender on page 10.
- Oh, OK. So you can say,
this is the page to stay at?
- Yeah. It's not something
that I've built directly.
But I've seen some like
pieces around doing something like that.
- Yeah. And I think Jeff
is saying use [? inputDTrow ?]
last click and rows selected.
But that's for the-- I mean,
does DT and rhandsontable
work together?
Do they work together
then? Is that how--
because those are DT--
anyway, maybe we're getting
into-- I don't know.
This is a hangout.
I don't know where the line is.
- I'm seeing,
in the comments,
somebody had recommended doing
a deep dive on this topic.
And I will definitely take that
on as an action item and ask
who from our team
might be interested.
-
I think it's just something
that so many people on data
teams have to deal
with. It doesn't matter how
powerful your backend is
if ultimately the business user,
who maybe has an
analyst on their team,
who is maybe comfortable in
Excel and can write some SQL--
it doesn't matter if they
can't interact with it as your
deliverable. And not
everything that you deliver is
suitable for an HTML markdown.
Sometimes, clickable graphs are
what you need. But sometimes,
people really like tables.
And people really need tables.
And so there are certain things
there where you have to meet
people where they
are on data science.
It doesn't do you any
good to be like, well,
have you tried doing it in R,
if the person doesn't
even know what that is.
So I think that's really,
really where I'm at on
some of these things where I'm
like, I have no hate for Excel.
I don't love it. But
I have no hate for it.
- Absolutely. Thank you.
I know, Travis, you had
a question, I think,
was maybe touched upon. But I
want to make sure we answer it
fully, if you want
to jump in here.
- Sure. I know
persistent data storage,
in particular writing
to data stores,
is not always easy in Shiny.
It sounds like you're using S3.
Good experience, I suppose?
I'm curious-- if you're
using rhandsontable,
I'm actually really curious
about the way that someone
would enter data into it,
and then send it to the
database, I suppose.
It's generally easy to report
out from it, and pull things
in, and summarize them. But
sending stuff is
harder, at least to me.
Maybe you've solved it.
- So we've solved it in
two ways that we
then work together.
My team built a package
that helps us handle our internal
S3 credentials
so that the app has the
service account credentials.
The app has access to S3
as part of setting up our
environment variables. So that was
the first thing that we did.
That didn't make it so that
the individual user needed to have
the right S3 access
to the bucket.
And then I also--
I'll say invented. Nobody invented
this-- but invented
it for this app.
We've got the Submit button.
And we also have a Save
For Later button where,
in terms of just like
naming these files, it's like, OK,
is this done?
Save it for later.
Every time you want to save
something, you can send it to
S3. And it saves that portion
of data that I would expect,
regardless of what's in it.
And it's tagged with
that Intermediate tag.
And then when they hit Submit,
then it's tagged
with that Done.
And what I actually have
as part of that interaction is,
in that display, when
you're going to say, OK,
what rows do I need to edit?
It brings that tag back in. So the
user knows what's
already been changed,
what are they maybe
still working on,
verse what are they
comfortable with that done.
But really just like a--
we've got it as a Save
RDS really from that S3
call, just save the RDS
because I'm the only one--
and my team-- who's going
to have access to, oh hey,
I need to know what I did
last month. I can go back.
And I can read RDFs and
write it to that
file for that person.
- That's super cool.
For the S3 needs,
is that just on
your Shiny team,
people that are
maintaining that backend infrastructure?
Or do you have cloud
support as well?
- That's part of
that corporate IT,
centralized. They
maintain our S3 storage.
So actuarial has
our own storage.
We also have a broader
Centene storage
and things like that.
And the IT team is in
charge of maintaining that.
And as I said at the beginning,
that's one of the things that
I'm grateful that I don't have
to know how to do it.
But I'm also very grateful that the
technology solution exists
and that I have access to it.
- Loving all of this table
discussion here, too.
I did just want to share in
the chat, I just learned that Rich,
who maintains the GT package,
started a GT Discord server,
which has been really helpful for
people to ask questions there, too.
Alan, I see you had asked
the question in the chat.
Do you want to
jump in here next?
- Yeah, hi.
This is super fun.
I love when the chat is just
excited and everybody is
enthusiastic and learning
stuff. It's really, really fun.
At the risk of
pivoting away from
that, Katherine,
I'm super curious what
your day to day is like.
We're obviously in
the technical weeds here.
And it's really great.
What's the balance of that
for you with leading, or managing,
or doing strategic stuff,
that kind of thing?
How much of that do you do?
And what's your what's your experience
doing that as a leader of--
working with the team
that you're working with?
- Yeah.
So I would say I'm
pretty-- maybe like 60/40
leadership to in the data.
And I think a lot of that
comes from the fact that I have been
at Centene-- I started
there as a data scientist I.
And I'm now a manager of
a data analytics team.
So a lot of the things
that I learned as a data science--
databases that I-- as a
data scientist, databases that I
got access to,
things like that,
where I'm really comfortable with
certain pieces of the job
is still really helpful for me
to be doing because I can still
do it reasonably quickly
and all of that.
And my team is
also pretty small.
I have two direct reports and
my sister team has three. And
so together, we're a data
science org of about eight.
And so we're a
pretty small team.
And so there's still a
lot of need for, hey,
can you do this for
me really quick?
But in terms of
strategic leadership
and direct management
of my team,
there's a lot involved in
terms of making sure that us,
as an embedded team,
stay up-to-date on what
the tech stack development looks
like, and where those
tools are going to live,
and how can we make sure
that we maintain access to the new
tools, and potentially
transition processes, but also
keep support for these
processes that aren't ready to
be transitioned yet.
So there is a lot of that
strategic leadership,
in terms of
project maintenance, because
when you're the actuarial
department of an insurance
company, you can't just
not file a rate or
not turn something
into the government. All of
this work still needs to go on,
while you're doing
all of the forward
initiatives with
your data science. So
there's a lot of that.
And then I've personally
been a lot more involved--
I'm on the leadership
council for our Women In STEM
initiative. So there's
a lot of that--
and our R user
group. But that's
a given here on the R
Hangout. But
there's a lot of that
community building and reaching out to
people that I've incorporated into
some of my leadership work of--
a lot of things is making
sure you know that other teams exist,
which, in an organization
at the size of Centene,
can be really difficult.
Just like, oh,
I didn't know that this team
was doing this kind of thing
with membership. I have a
need to do something with
membership. Let me make sure that
I know who to reach out to.
And that's something
that we've been
really working hard on.
In our next internal
R user group meeting--
and we're trying to do it a
little bit in every one moving forward-- is
someone just
highlighting their team.
And this is what we're doing.
This is how we're using
the Centene tools.
It's not always R.
But it's just this is
how we're using our data.
This is the data
science that we're doing
to keep those
relationships built. Again,
I think going back to
something I said earlier,
I did it for me. And then
I'm more than happy that it's helping
other people also
in Centene.
- That's great. Thank you.
I really appreciate hearing that.
I was curious also about your
journey to the role that you're
in. So knowing that you
started as a data scientist,
moved into and through
the organization is
also really interesting to
know. Thank you. Appreciate it.
- Yeah, you're welcome.
I don't think my journey
into data science is particularly
different from anyone
else's on this call.
I have an applied
science background.
I biomedical engineering
and applied math.
And I didn't want a PhD. So
I got a data science job.
And I think that's a story that
will resonate with many people on this call.
- I want to make sure I get
to some of the anonymous
questions, too. I see
somebody had asked
on Slido--
and I think it was when
you were describing the Shiny app
you created
perhaps. But it was,
is this aggregated information
across all suppliers provided
on some de-identified way to
the public or all the suppliers?
And I can copy the question.
- So it is not provided
to the public. It is
anonymized, but it is not
de-identified to the point of meeting
HIPAA compliance. So this is
individual data that we get back
summary
results by state and potentially
by health plan are available
at the end of the audit
on the government HHS websites.
But you would not have access
to this member-level
ACA Marketplace information anywhere.
- OK. Thank you.
Lisa,
I see you had just asked a
question here in the Zoom chat.
You want to jump in?
- Sure.
I had to move down to
my first floor because our second floor
is like a sauna here.
And I'm in Minnesota.
We've gone from winter
to summer very quickly.
Yeah, I was just curious
how your team's work
divides up maybe between machine
learning-type tasks, and then other
reporting, summarizing,
presenting,
essentially every other
kind of data science work,
and then if that--
do you feel like the
organization or business
appreciates both pieces
of that work? And does
how much it's getting noticed
and used match with how much
time you're spending
in each of those?
- I would definitely say yes
to the second part of that.
My organization and my
reporting pipeline are very
interested in those kinds
of machine learning improvements
not just for the sake of
saying that we're doing machine learning,
but for the sake of this is
improving this forecast that we
have or this thing like that.
We're thrilled that there are
tools available to help us
improve that. So that's great.
And then in terms of
balancing the work,
because we do have busy
seasons with audit conduction and then
a little bit of downtime
before we're back up on audit,
we tend to do a lot of the
data science work during our
downtime of audit because those
are the things that make when
we do kick off the audit
easier. But also, during that time,
we have a lot more less
technical business partners who
need summarization
of that data.
They need weekly reporting
in a downloadable format,
or a graph, or things like
that. So for us, we're lucky
that a lot of those things
have been able to be automated based
on the way that we're
storing, and accessing,
and running these reports.
But there's still plenty of
need for I think-- like I said,
Oh, we weren't tracking
that last year. Now,
we have nothing in place
to track that because that's a
problem and doing
some of that scramble.
There is always some
of that data wrangling,
data display scramble when
you run into a new issue.
And then during our
downtime, we bake that into
models, to reporting,
things like that so that we
don't run into it next year.
Thanks.
- Thank you.
[? Faresa, ?] I see you
had asked a question in the chat.
Do you want to
jump in here next?
- Sure.
I was just asking actually
what your tech stack is.
So are you running
Posit in the cloud?
Or are you running it locally?
The reason I'm asking the
question is I'm from Canada,
also in insurance.
But we have very strict
rules around our data.
So we've only been able to
stay locally for right now.
So I'm just curious how you
ended up building out that stack bit.
- Yeah. So we have
some of the Posit
Professional tools.
We have the Package
Manager and rsconnect.
I think we're
currently running R in
JupyterHub,
through that. But all of
our data is on-prem right now.
And so our corporate,
centralized IT has built a lot
of protections around different environments
where you can publish things.
And it needs to be
approved through the certain pipeline
for PHI and all of
that kind of stuff.
So there are some heavy
considerations with publishing
any information,
even internally
for internal use,
going back to not everyone has
access to the same level of PHI
within this organization,
so being really careful
about where that's displayed.
Like I said, all
of our databases are on-prem.
And then those different
environments that they've set
up have access to
different levels of that information.
- Thank you.
-
And maybe if there is anybody
else who's based in Canada and
wants to comment in the chat to
help [? Faresa ?] out as well,
feel free.
Another anonymous question
was, how has the push for
value-based care impacted how
your risk adjustment is done?
- So value-based care,
for those who are not aware, is
a method of paying providers based on
some metric of care value
that they're providing.
Whether it is risk
adjustment capture,
whether it is
medication management or whatever,
it's usually a contractual
arrangement with your provider.
So it's something--
not all providers are in
value-based care arrangements.
And that's not actually-- from
the grand scheme of government
mandated risk adjustment,
they don't care what
your provider
arrangement looks like.
So for us, on the
backend, that's part of plan design.
So if we're going to say
these members can sign up for this
kind of network within
this value-based care arrangement,
we still--
there might be different
premiums associated with that,
different aspects of the plan
design that feed the risk
adjustment transfers.
So what that comes down to,
in terms of risk adjustment,
is understanding the population that
is participating in that plan.
So different people may choose
to select different plans based
on their own personal needs
on the marketplace. And so
understanding what is driving
whatever subset of members to
enroll in these plans is really
where some of the analytics
that our risk adjustment
actuarial team is doing. Because
of how you price it,
how you design that,
then you come back
and say, OK, well,
what is the risk
of these members?
- Thank you.
I think that we are not
doing the best job of tracking some
of the questions
in between some--
- I see there's a lot of
that around [? Zelda ?]
and how hot it is currently.
Libby and I are
both in San Antonio.
And
it is hot. We're reaching
Don't Go Outside season.
- Well, I know there are a
lot of great questions in there, too.
So feel free to just raise your
hand here on Zoom if there was
something you had
that we missed.
But I see, Libby, you
had a question about
moving from individual
contributor role.
Do you want to jump in there?
- Yeah, this is
always my most--
this is the thing I'm
most interested in always.
It's like you have moved
from an individual contributor role
to something that at
least involves people management,
project management, bigger
stuff that might pull you away
from boots on the ground work.
How do you feel about that?
How did you feel about
making that transition?
And how has that been?
How did that come to be?
- I feel great about it.
I think it's something
that fits within
my personal evaluation of my own
skill set. So I was ready
for that transition.
But I think one of the things
that really helped me with that is,
in my individual
contributor role,
there were certain projects that
I was wholly responsible for already.
And so I knew a
little bit about managing that project,
what was involved in terms
of talking to the people.
So I was already
doing that for myself.
And then as I got
promoted in my pipeline,
I actually had a really great
leadership mentor
talking me through how he
was managing his team, setting
me up with like, OK,
now that you're taking
over this responsibility,
these are my primary
contacts. So somebody really
set me up for success
in that transition into
the people leadership.
Something that I've
had to balance with myself is
part of that--
there are certain things
that I'm very good at.
And I have a
lot of experience within Centene.
But now, if I choose to spend
my time doing that, that's
time that I'm taking
away from something else.
So balancing that I do need
to train people to do this task
because that's no longer
my primary responsibility is
something that I've been
navigating and trying to get
better at, especially during times
when it's not like, hey,
we need to turn this around
in three hours because if that's
the deadline, I'm going to do it.
But if we have 24 hours or
even three weeks,
that's something that I can
spend the time teaching someone
how to do it right once,
and then facilitating
that in the future.
- That's really
helpful. Thank you.
- Yeah.
- Was there a specific
point where you thought, OK,
I'm ready to move
from this individual contributor role?
- I don't think so.
I think it was
just something that
my reporting chain was
generally very supportive of
moving any people through the career
direction that they want to go.
And so as I went from data
scientist I to data scientist
II and my responsibilities grew
and I was feeling comfortable,
it was like, hey, do you think
you're ready for this? And I said,
sure.
And then once you say sure
that you're ready for it,
you then have to be because
now you're doing it.
And there's no room to be
like, oh, just kidding.
Please unpromote me.
Yeah, I felt like I was
ready. And then as I made that
transition, my reporting
chain was still intact.
And so I still had that support
from the top down to help me as
I learned how to support the
people that now report to me.
- Something that's been hard
for me is when that
career track doesn't
already exist for your role,
figuring out how to
then go from individual
contributor to a manager, and
if it's like creating your
own role or finding a different
part within the organization where
that would fit in as well.
- Yeah, so I think
that's something
we've worked with
our HR partners--
being embedded in the
actuarial department,
I think before I was hired
in as a data scientist,
everyone in that org had
to have actuarial titles,
even though these were
people not pursuing actuarial
credentials or anything like that.
So there was a big push
to say, OK,
we're actually allowed to
hire people with data titles
into this role.
So it can feel like
there's a lot of swimming
upstream there because
there is corporate inertia.
There's a reason that these
orgs were built this way when
it started. But having
someone who understands
that the corporate needs are
changing and there's a need to
hire people with these different skills
can be really valuable
in designing that.
And then
if you're moving into
a management position but
there hasn't historically been one,
it's working with
them to say, OK, well,
what do these job posts
look like in other orgs,
going through the
whole process of, OK,
let's just copy and paste
that, but put it in this org.
Or maybe we need to change
what tools does this
person have to know.
But that's part of
that conversation.
- Yeah, thank you.
Zachary, I see you had asked
a question in the chat.
There's stars next to it.
So I'll read it. But it was,
how do you and your team generally
keep track of all the R packages?
For example,
we discussed so many even
in this Hangout and also new
packages that come out.
There's just so much.
- So we have, in our
biweekly team meeting,
after we go around and
we say what everyone's been working
on, what do they
need any help with,
we actually have a little
slide that's called R Spotlight. And
there's a web scraper that just runs.
And it lists all like, oh, here's
what's from the New in
this packages from the--
I'm blanking on the
name of that R Weekly.
I think it might be R Weekly
update.
It scrapes that and just plops
it into our team's slides
for us. And so
when me or the other manager
have a little time before the meeting,
we'll go through that and pick
out the ones that we think we
should individually highlight.
But even that, we've got
some like keyword searches.
But it brings it in, so
it always stays on our radar,
even if you're not paying
super close attention.
And then we also have, within
our data science community, a couple
R-devoted channels.
So if somebody is asking
a question about a package or
about something
that they heard,
we can keep an eye on that
and be like, OK, yeah,
there's now been four
questions about this package.
Let's learn a little bit more
about it. So all of that say,
I think I kind of outsourced
knowing everything
that's going on in R
to the point where it does
filter to the top of my
consciousness that's something that
I actually should learn about.
- That's great. Thank you. I
was just copying over into chat
R Weekly as well for
people to check out.
Greg, I see you have a
question in the chat here, too.
Do you want to jump in?
- Yes. Can you hear me?
- Yeah.
- It took me a minute
to get off mute.
- No worries.
- Yeah. So I heard, at the
beginning, you mentioned that
if you get multiple requests
for the same thing, that you'll
then talk about building
something that's self-service,
or an app, or
whatever it might be.
To keep track of all those, do
you maintain any kind of data analytics
roadmap?
Or do you do anything to
assess the value of multiple requests?
- Yeah.
So our primary method for
tracking that is actually we
use GitLab. And we have issues,
and epics, and milestones
related to a lot of that,
and then can use the
comments of like,
got asked for this again,
something like
that to prioritize.
We have been having
to do a lot more with
value analytics,
in terms of saying
to prioritize our work,
because we've started getting
more and more as we've
integrated with more teams,
taking on more responsibilities
to say like, OK, well,
what's the priority for us?
Divorcing the
this is valuable to me and my
team and would save us time verse
this is what's valuable
to the organization.
And this is the amount of
money that we will save,
or not spend, or whatever
if we implement this
is something that does require a little
bit of tracking and a little bit of--
we work with our corporate
IT partners to say, OK,
if we put this much data
on this storage solution,
how much is that going to
cost to maintain it in this way?
And all of those
kinds of discussions,
that goes back to what are
my responsibilities now as a
manager versus an
individual contributor,
is having to think
about stuff like that.
But a lot of it is,
in terms of the
multiple requests,
it would be like we ran a
report once and it was ad hoc.
And now, we've gotten asked
for it a couple of times.
The code still exists.
And it's not a lot of
ground-up development.
It's just a matter of
putting it in the right
spot, so like on rsconnect,
and just scheduling it
or something like that,
where it's not a
huge lift there.
But it then gets us more cred,
as we've got another
thing published.
And then you have some of those
other considerations about log in, and PHI,
and stuff like that once you
get it get it to that point.
So it's not no development.
But it's not ground-up. The
ground-up work takes a lot more
value prioritization.
- Sure, cool. I
appreciate that.
- So is that a budget
that you have to control,
the storage spend, for example?
- I am not in charge of it.
But I need to be aware of it.
The person in charge
of the budget ultimately decides
whether or not they're willing
to spend the budget on the
value that you've built
around your project--
not only gathering the value
and determining it, but then
saying, hey, I need you to
spend your money on this project.
Some of it is our money that
we control. But some of it is
corporate spend dollars
for different aspects of IT
development, technology
spend, things like that.
So you have to come in.
And then they have
their own prioritization for projects.
And different other teams who
have data science needs and
technology needs, maybe
they need it today.
And I don't need
it for two months.
And so that kind of
prioritization-- then you're
like, oh great,
I'm done with this.
And then you have to keep it
on your back burner for two months
and not lose sight of it
as it goes through that whole process.
- Thank you.
I see Bill had asked a question
a bit earlier that was,
do you have a
corporate structure with a distinct
function which assures
compliance with government regulations?
If so, does your team--
sorry, it's a little longer
question. If so, does your
team, IT and compliance,
which could maybe be called
QA in pharma, work together on
your applications?
- Yeah, so we do have--
we have a compliance team.
So we have government
compliance teams.
And then we also have IT SOX-compliant
teams.
And both of those things
do need to come together.
There's code review. There's
distinction of data access
reviews as you go through
publishing these out. So
those teams are not married,
government compliance and
IT compliance officially.
But both of those pieces have
to come together in order to
get something in the works.
-
I love what you said about
making sure that you know other
teams exist across the
organization and figuring out
what everybody
else is working on.
And I was wondering, aside from
the community event,
how do you start to
build those relationships or figure out,
in such a large organization,
who you should talk to?
- I think it starts small.
When
you're really close to a
data project and there's one piece
that you don't know,
it's like shooting the email to
the person that you saw last
accessed that database because
you can check those things.
You can say like, hey, I saw
you were using this data.
What's going on with it? And
so those kinds of small emails--
and it's also getting over
that hump of self-doubt,
like, oh, am I emailing
the right person?
Are they going to
hate me for derailing their
day for emailing the wrong person?
And just send an email because
the worst thing that happens is
that they don't respond to you. And
then you send an email to another person
and building that out.
And then as I've moved through
into a leadership role,
it's getting plugged in with
other team leaders, where they--
OK. Now, I know the
name of your team.
But do you have somebody on
your team who knows about this
or who can help with this?
And that's also
something that the
Women in STEM group has helped
with because we have women in
STEM across the
entire organization.
They are not just in
corporate IT as your cloud engineers.
Almost anyone with a data
analyst title or anything like
that could count.
And a lot of people in
health insurance have those math backgrounds.
I've been exposed to so many
more people and so many more
incredible women at Centene
through that other organization that
now I know there's a new
team, our member
insights team--
brand new team, but I'm like,
their manager immediately got plugged
in with Women in STEM.
So now, I'm connected to her
on both pieces. So it's really great
to be able to have that.
- I love that.
That's a great,
great community anecdote there.
It doesn't just have to
be the data science community where
you are meeting all these
other people across different parts
of the organization.
I just want to double-check
with everybody here in the chat.
I think there are a lot of
people who I think need to play
some sort of game together
because there's a lot of talk
about a certain game.
But I just want to make
sure there are no other questions
that I might have missed.
One question I love to ask for
my own knowledge here is, if you think
back to your
career and as you're getting to--
gotten your role now, is there
a piece of advice that comes
to mind that you received along
the way or a favorite piece
of career advice that you've ever given?
- I think
it's something that, even coming
into this meeting, where I'm like--
I'm great. And then I'm
also like, oh my goodness,
what if people find
out I'm not great?
That
sort of imposter
syndrome, of just-- let
people believe in you until
you can believe in yourself,
where it's like no
one's giving you
opportunities that they
don't think that you can do
because everybody's
looking out for themselves.
I've given that advice.
I give myself that
advice because it is--
let other people
believe in you. And
I think that that's
something that makes
the most difference.
And it comes even
back around to
if you think you're doing OK,
send that email to the stranger and
hope that they can help you with
your data.
So it's just like, yeah,
you probably have the
opportunities that you have
because you earned them.
- I absolutely love that.
Thank you so much, Katherine.
If people want to get
in touch with you,
is the best way LinkedIn?
- It is. I am not generally
super active on posting
on social media. But I am
a scroller. So if you reach out
to me on LinkedIn,
I will get it.
- Awesome. I just put it in,
your LinkedIn there
in the chat as well.
And it will be up
with the recording on the Data
Science Hangout site. But
thank you so much,
Katherine. This has been
a great conversation.
And thank you for sharing
your experience with us all.
- Yeah, thank you
for having me.